Speaker 1: I have a clip for you today.
That is one of the most dangerous clips I
can remember ever playing on this program.
And the reason it's dangerous isn't because
the person in the video, Candace Owens, is
uniquely dangerous herself.
There's if you go on the New York subway platform,
right?
As as I often do, you see unhinged people
saying wacky things?
They're yelling them.
Sometimes they're yelling at no one, but they're
not dangerous because no one's paying attention
to them.
If the crazy subway guy and I don't mean that
Jared Guy from Subway, the commercial, I mean
the New York subway.
If the crazy New York subway guy had a million
people following them on social media and
150 or 200 or 300 people paying to hear them
speak, we would say, Well, that's Subway Guy
is really dangerous.
That's the case with Candace Owens in this
clip.
Now, remember, Candace Owens falsely claimed
that the comedian Bob Saget probably died
from the COVID vaccine.
He died from a hit to the head.
OK, here she is, saying she believes they
they intentionally killed people in hospitals
during COVID.
And people clap and people nod and people
agree.
Speaker 3: Well, I am a big believer that
they intentionally kill people in hospitals
during Cobra.
Speaker 1: Now who is they?
OK, so let's take let's pretend that this
these claims were subjected to actual standards
vs. Candice.
Who is they?
Is it the nurses?
Is it the doctors?
Is it hospital administrators?
Did some kind of covert government operatives
infiltrate the hospital and sneak around and
the nurses didn't notice?
And who is they
Speaker 3: let family members in there to
make decisions for them?
I personally saw when I went to an asthma
clinic that they would not give me lifesaving
asthma treatment because breathing was not
allowed, even though they had the nebulizer.
Speaker 1: Breathing was not allowed.
Candice, who didn't allow breathing.
And how did you survive if you weren't allowed
to breathe
Speaker 3: and if they had not sent an ambulance,
I mean, I would.
Asthma attack is about like you've got a very
short window of time.
I was having an asthma attack and the doctor
had the life saving medicine and said that
the CDC had barred them from giving it to
me.
So there was no question that they colluded
to kill American citizens so that they could
fluff numbers and say that people died of
COVID.
I do.
I still, to this day, question the use of
ventilators.
It makes entirely no sensible need oxygen,
not compression on their chest when they're
dealing with something that's in their chest.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, the ventilator
doesn't deprive you of oxygen.
Speaker 3: So from top to bottom, yes, our
government wants people to die.
There's no question.
Speaker 1: Now understand that there's often
a conflict with a lot of these conspiracy
theories.
She says they were they were killing people
to fluff up COVID death numbers.
Others say the numbers are just bogus.
The numbers are invented out of thin air.
And of course, there's a conflict there, right?
Because if the numbers are just invented out
of thin air to make the death seem high, why
would you need to go in and kill people in
order for them to be really dead and reported
as COVID deaths because they're just making
up the numbers?
You don't need both.
It's a conflict.
It doesn't matter
Speaker 3: because it beat the narrative,
and it's it's we're talking about crimes against
humanity.
People should face long prison sentences.
People, people should face tribunals because
of what they did tribunals.
Speaker 1: What are you talking about during
COVID?
Speaker 3: And not even that the massing of
children, the treatment of special needs kids
that were being forced to be masked on planes
that were having, you know, essentially the
trauma that was put people on a site on a
psychological level.
Speaker 1: Right.
He's now speaking to the emotional trauma.
Speaker 3: Yeah, he should bring forth tribunals.
People like Bill Gates and Dr. Fauci should
be in prison.
Rachel Walensky What what?
Speaker 1: What crime did Bill Gates commit
to?
Speaker 3: Among them, this was corruption
top to bottom, and it was all done because
they had already predestined the vaccine right.
They did deny treatment.
They denied that the use of hydroxychloroquine.
Speaker 1: Now now remember.
If this was subjected to actual rigor, we
would say, what evidence do you have that
hydroxychloroquine works for treating COVID
and she would either not know or she would
say, I don't know, there's the 35 person study
from France or whatever, and we would say,
Well, we have randomized controlled trials.
We have really good rand, we have proper science
and it shows that it doesn't work now, she
says.
Speaker 3: Ivermectin, ivermectin.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Same thing with ivermectin.
What evidence do you have that ivermectin
works for COVID?
There is none that is randomized controlled
trials.
They say it doesn't work, but it's it's it's
diarrhea of dishonesty.
Speaker 3: The media was complicit in it and
it infuriates me.
It infuriates me that people that were allowed
to die and to suffer when there were medicines
that work because they knew that they could
not get emergency use authorization if there
was.
All right.
Speaker 1: So, you know, you hear stuff like
this and remember people who believe this
stuff sit on juries.
I've told my story of when I when I had jury
duty on my 21st birthday and it was appalling.
It was appalling that it was a simple self-defense
assault case, and a third of the jury did
not even understand the law.
It wasn't about we disagree about the facts.
It wasn't about we have different opinions
about who's credible.
A third of the jury didn't understand the
law that was supposed to be adjudicated used
to adjudicate the facts of the case.
So the people who believe over the ventilators
deprive you of oxygen or they killed people.
These people are on juries.
They teach school.
They might be your dentists, they might be
your accountant.
I don't know.
But but more critically, you know, if they're
your dentist and you don't like them, you
get a different dentist.
You can't choose your jury.
You only to some degree, can choose your kid's
teachers or whatever the case may be.
These people are extraordinarily dangerous
and they have followers.
And it's absolutely horrifying.